today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure
their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
yang
i am very confident that joe is going to
win this thing
i'm not sure if it's going to be tuesday
night reporting style
but i'm very confident that he's going
to win this thing if votes are counted
in the process
holds up there is a real chance that
that
there's a blue wave all around the
country i genuinely think that
um in a time when 72 to 80 percent of
americans think is the worst time
in their lifetimes that that's not like
an incumbent
type atmosphere you know especially when
this incumbent does not seem like the
guy who's going to lead you out
so i think there's going to be a blue
wave i think uh the
the democratic majority in the house is
going to grow
the senate's gonna flip um there's gonna
be a unified government
that's the way i think this is going to
[Music]
go
[Music]
tomorrow is the day andrew
tomorrow this is the special election
day eve edition of yang speaks
it's like christmas eve and instead of
christmas presents
it's a new government
it is like i will say this like it's a
moment of reflection like we
like if donald trump hadn't won in 2016
you wouldn't have run for president
right um true so this is like a
culmination day
um where you know rubber meets the road
whatever
analogy you want like that's kind of i
mean it's there's no way around it it's
important
you know i believe that donald trump is
going to lose and lose significantly but
let's take the first
part of this conversation to explore the
fork in the road where he
wins and then there's the middle ground
where he doesn't win but the process is
just such a disaster
that the count drags on and there's
unrest and he refuses to acknowledge and
uh the supreme court
um comes up with a new ruling that says
that president trump can do whatever he
wants
i should have laughed but i mean this is
like the middle zone
of um of
muddiness that uh prevents us from
having a clean
winner not just election night but
days and weeks thereafter so let's
consider
each scenario in turn scenario number
one donald trump wins clean
uh as in just wins more votes and
does and then you have with each
tributary it's like
quick and then slow um i don't think
there's a version where donald trump
wins slow is there let's see
let's review so there are three states
that are going to count votes more
slowly
um and those three states are the states
that uh you don't want them to be
they are michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania so
uh so you can imagine hang on one sec
let's just let me let me do this for
anybody who is listening who doesn't
unders doesn't follow politics doesn't
know what the [ __ ] going on
like there's like i i want to play dumb
because i used to be really dumb
on this so just for context real quick i
want you there's so much noise out there
andrew i hopefully break this down for
you
there's 538 total electoral college
votes
you need 270 votes to win
and essentially a lot of them are
already baked so there's really like 201
votes up for grabs um
because 331 of them are so are already
locked um
so with that context andrew take away
um i didn't mean i meant to interrupt
you but but only because
if there's um the path to 270 yeah
completely yeah
i i was assuming that folks know that
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
are swing states or battleground states
uh and so those three states
not having their votes in on election
night
will likely present a problem like it's
not a situation where
you can pencil them in as blue or red
so if we're going to get a quick result
on election night
it's going to not involve those three
states right uh it's
very hard for me to imagine a scenario
where pennsylvania in particular
is just so clearly for one candidate
that they call it despite the fact that
a lot of votes haven't been counted
um i i like i don't see them calling
pennsylvania
uh or michigan or wisconsin for that
matter there was one poll that came out
that had
joe biden up by 17 in wisconsin
yeah so so it's conceivable that
wisconsin just goes so
much for joe that even with the mail and
vote not
entirely counted that people are
comfortable calling it um still
something
i see is unlikely so election night
scenarios
you have to contemplate them without
knowing any of those three states
uh results
[Music]
uh joe has an advantage in paths to 270.
he has a lot more paths to get there
trump needs to essentially win every
state that he needs to win to get to 270
270's close to his ceiling there is a
world where joe biden's ceiling
is 350 like where he just wins by a mile
um so the main scenario for joe
to become the clear winner tuesday night
is if some of the big um battleground
states that are not those three go to
him
so let's say florida north carolina if
florida and north carolina go to joe
then he might be able to get to 270 even
without
any of the three slower states
so you've got so there's there's a cool
website if you guys want to mess around
with because i have been it's called
it's 272702win.com
to win.com and you can just make your
own map so for me like i like to
you can listen to pundits you listen to
us but it's nice to kind of
your own for me is like look at my own
math like what would happen what states
i'm watching personally
um there's seven states i think that
really matter
uh it's you just said a bunch of them
but it's michigan wisconsin pennsylvania
ohio florida north carolina arizona
that's what you're looking at
and essentially biden wins three of
those
it's over um if he wins florida it's
pretty much
over all in right if tru if he wins just
florida
by the numbers that won't happen he'll
probably want any one of the others but
if he wins florida
it's probably pretty much close to over
um trump needs five so that's where the
like
biden is favored is because of basically
that math these are all toss-ups
leaning joe in many cases um
so i think the likely path and one of
you agree with like if you like
had to guess the likely path if either
of them win um
the likely path for joe to win is that
he takes michigan wisconsin
arizona and probably pennsylvania
because in all of those he's favored
he's got
an 85 to 94
chance of winning all four of those you
know individually
um and then trump if he wins he
basically has to win
florida north carolina ohio which he's
winning in and then he'd have to take
pennsylvania and then one of
whatever's next either and you could
probably throw it exactly
so if so florida and north carolina go
to joe it's pretty much all she wrote
that's the election i key if so that
comes in election night then
we we go to sleep knowing that joe's
going to be um
president and uh the transition occurs
hopefully pretty straightforwardly where
if it's that clean it's going to be very
hard for donald trump not to concede
i know that some people in the bind
campaign are actually strategizing
around trying to get
a quick knockout by investing more
heavily in florida and north carolina
though they had me campaign in
pennsylvania so they're leaving nothing
to chance that they're not right
they don't seem to be over emphasizing
the timing of the thing they just want
to win
which is the right approach you know
you're just gonna win
we are in month eight of the quarantine
it's getting harder and harder to stay
fit to feed yourself
right i don't know by the rest of you
but if you started out eating healthy
you might not be eating healthy now but
we have found
the product that's going to help turn it
around for you it's going to make you
feel like a million bucks going to get
some green into your system it even has
green in the name
it's athletic greens you mix it with
water
you take it and it's like this high-tech
yet super
healthy and organic nutritional
supplement it's got a probiotic for gut
health
it boosts your immune system uh it helps
you digest
it's got 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food sourced ingredients it's almost
like
um like a nutrition shoot super shot
in the form of a quick drink andrew i
think you joked once that anyone that
loses weight or gets in shape during
covid
should be running the country so if you
want to be one of the people andrew yang
thinks
should be running the country athletic
greens is probably the way to go because
this puts you in shape and even if
you're not working out
your body feels at ease i just felt my
stomach be more balanced
i find that i don't chew my food fast
enough it's a bit of a problem
and this helps so if you're looking to
upgrade your multivitamin
or take one nutritional formula that's
going to help you cover your daily
nutritional bases then you want to
consider athletic
greens athletic creams makes getting as
much high quality nutrition
as possible incredibly easy without the
need to buy multiple products so
so make an investment in your health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle and support your
immunity
gut health and energy holy crap your
energy
trust me on this one by visiting
athleticgreens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d for free
which i love is like an energy drop
into your drink with your first purchase
so that's again
athleticgreens.com
[Music]
so you've got so florida according to
538 which i think is the they were the
closest
essentially at least putting public
press outlets because they aggregate all
the polls and just do an algorithm
they're the closest to predicting 2016
they said hillary had a
71 chance of winning where the rest of
the press said it was
well into the high 90s um
they are saying that biden has a 62
chance of winning florida
and um 64 chance of winning north
carolina those are toss-ups
those are you know it's roll the die um
it's going to come down to turnout
and possibly some you know shenanigans
with uh
mail-in voting or coveted voting if you
will
but that's where you agree i mean they
can start saying that's where we focus
and if biden wins one of those it's
great florida in particular
we're gonna have a biden's gonna have a
good night we agree
yeah so that that's where you should be
um investing in paying attention
uh certainly on election night uh
and you should not hold your breath
waiting for pennsylvania wisconsin or
michigan and not don't worry about it
like the fact that those aren't going to
be reported
doesn't tell you that uh joe's gonna win
or not win
there everybody loses those it's not
over either sorry to be clear
like if i lose north carolina florida
you still got plenty of paths to victory
sorry
yeah and that is a possibility
historically north carolina has been
tougher terrain for democrats and
uh florida too slightly uh i'm very
confident that joe's gonna win this
thing
uh i'm not sure if it's gonna be
tuesday night reporting style but i'm
very confident that he's going to win
this thing if votes are counted and the
process
holds up so there so let's consider
again each of them in turn there are a
number of variables though some of the
variables extend
beyond election night so i guess we'll
just focus on election night so you're
right to look at the map
uh as the election returns come in
definitely it's gonna be very exciting
um but if these states start getting
called for joe then that's enormous
and there is a real chance that that
there's a blue wave
all around the country i genuinely think
that um
in a time when 72 to 80 of americans
think is the worst time
in their lifetimes that that's not like
an incumbent
type atmosphere you know especially when
this incumbent does not seem like the
guy who's going to lead you out
right so i think there's going to be a
blue wave i think uh the
the democratic majority in the house is
going to grow
the senate's going to flip um there's
going to be a unified government
that's the way i think this is going to
go
uh and i love your confidence election
night
is about the presidential race first and
foremost
um but now that i have been endorsing
all of these down ballot candidates
some of whom are hardcore gang gang some
of whom are for cash relief
um there's virtually no one on the list
that's not one of those two things
like if you're really i mean if we
endorsed you
for cash relief yeah uh
so i'm going to be very very intent
on seeing what happens to a lot of these
candidates particularly
a lot of the um challengers to
incumbents
being an incumbent member of congress is
so hard
under ordinary circumstances it's one
reason why you notice anytime it does
happen because it just never happens um
but i think if there's going to be a
time for it to happen it's going to be
this time
so for context the historical reelection
rate for an incumbent member of congress
is 94 that's sky high
that's better than the golden state
warriors in their record year kind of
high
good analogy but so it is so if this
time it's going to be lower though
because you have a lot of
um a lot of incumbents who are
vulnerable or in a contested race
and you're seeing record levels of
turnout as we're having this
conversation
like you know 75 million americans have
voted already
uh and by the time people are hearing
this on monday it's going to be
a significantly larger number and then
everyone's going to turn out on tuesday
so you're i saw projections that said
that this
might be the highest turnout uh in
60 years because of mail-in voting
and early voting i think we should keep
mail in voting and early voting i think
it works better
i know who wants to just just have
everything be banking on
everyone showing up at the same time one
day just let us know
yeah so so you have to imagine an
incredibly high turnout environment
and that's generally going to help dems
um
so the size and enormity of the blue
wave
and whether it crashes down in places
like texas
and alaska and south carolina
georgia so interesting to me
this really could redefine the american
political landscape
uh for a long time i mean if texas goes
blue
uh well that's over yeah we see texas go
it's it's over
oh yeah that would be incredible uh
that's i don't necessarily expect that
sorry beto i mean you know i
expect it to be very very tight um but i
i doubt it's gonna get called for joe
um tuesday night but if it were to yeah
it's over
i'll just call it
[Music]
one of the things that's going to keep
your you mentally balanced
during this time is to keep learning new
things and skillshare
is a fantastic way that you can learn
among thousands of other people among
thousands of different classes and
offerings
they've got everything under the sun
from the
golden oldies of photoshop and adobe
software
to something much more crazy like
i don't know what well i'm actually i'm
legitimately actually taking one of
these courses on
iphone photography because on the
campaign i was so bad
and john our digital expert on the
campaign
and now producer of the podcast taught
me some tricks but uh you can do wonders
with that freaking phone particularly
some of the new ones
um so that's my favorite class it's
called iphone photography
how to i want to make sure i get this
right how to shoot and edit conceptual
photos on your phone
taught by the adobe creative uh resident
one of their creative residents at adobe
so
um you can get whether it's like a fun
cool hobby you always want to pick up or
some like really practical like finance
or uh software stuff you need for your
day to day like quickbooks or whatever
it is you can get a whole bunch of
fancy creative interesting stuff on
skillshare
yeah skillshare is the hub for this
stuff they've got a community of
hundreds of thousands even millions of
people
enjoying the 21st century way to learn
so if you want to explore your
creativity go to skillshare.com
yangspeaks and the first thousand people
to use our link will get a free trial
of skillshare premium membership ooh
receive free access to thousands of
classes for a limited time
be one of the first thousand to sign up
at skillshare.com
yang speaks wow that's a great deal
[Music]
so let me ask you this like what's gonna
happen is you're gonna start having
you're going to have you're going to
have these states i mentioned start
reporting
some results because they're going to be
counting
and i think turnout model is going to be
all over the map right so people are
going to be afraid
to your point i think you have record i
think you have turned out like we've
never seen before from people of all and
on both sides yeah i think dems maybe
net benefit but republicans have a lot
of turnout too
if you start to see like i i kind of
want your perspective on how to help our
listeners
watch the results come in on election
night when they start to see wisconsin
numbers come in
when you know they're going to take a
couple days to tally everything like
do they like you know let's say it's 25
of results are in and they start
announcing do you feel comfortable with
that
do you uh does that mean nothing because
it's going to flip
the next time well this is why it gets
very frustrating zach it just depends
upon
where the 25 is from um if it's 25
from an urban area in wisconsin then
you'd expect it to skew very heavily
democratic and then
you take it with a massive grain of salt
if somehow they were to say to you this
25
is a representative cross section of the
whole state uh
then statistically you could say all
right i guess we know what's happening
right that's one reason why they keep
digging into which counties it's from
because if you're an experienced
political journalist you know which uh
which direction a county is supposed to
go right
the thing i look for is results that
surprise
that surprised the journalist involved
where there's some place and they were
like well
i remember during the weekend after
super tuesday
where they were digging into what was
happening in ann arbor michigan
and they were like if bernie doesn't win
this county by like a million votes or
whatever
you know then it's going to be a really
rough night um so
it's that kind of thing where if they
can find an anomaly um
then that's a sign uh but the the raw
vote totals uh it's hard to tell because
you don't know what counties are coming
from
have you been following um i think
there's this like innate fear that the
president
will tweet out that he's won a certain
state or won the election
um before any of the networks have
called or
all the votes are in and normally that's
not as big of a problem because normally
like the
the lagging votes are either a small
number or
on par with you know the way the state
was trending but in this case they could
be way off right like
most of them democrats mail their votes
in and they haven't been counted like
there's a lot there's a lot of
room for error there any thoughts on
either how like your twitters or
facebooks handle that or
how we as americans should handle you
know president or anyone's early call
the social media companies have said
that they are going to clamp down on any
claim of victory that's not
independently verified by various
national media organizations so the ap
would be one big verifier
everyone's going to wait in the media
companies to call it uh and if trump
says i won
that then i think they'll probably ban
it honestly
i mean that's what they've already come
out and said they've said that
there is no independent yeah they should
do that and they should do it if joe did
the same thing
you know it's only fair uh that'd be
pretty funny if joe was like i won
i would like hours early it'd be like
noon on
noon on tuesday be like i already won
where after the races
oh my gosh uh yeah we all know
it's directed at trump this ban uh or
edict
um it also does show the power of the
social media platforms i mean talk about
it
um that's wild so i'm gonna break down
for a minute why i'm so confident
uh because a lot of people are but i'm
not as confident i'm gonna probably take
the other side
here yeah i'm fascinated on behalf of
all of our listeners
i'm fascinated by what you're about to
say
here at yang speaks we're all about
trying to make our lives better
and one thing we do a whole lot of is
sleep
i remember going into the old mattress
store when i was younger
and i was like ooh matches like uh so
expensive what's going on
but happily like a lot of other things
in our lives mattresses have got an
upgrade
and now the best mattress you can get
for folks who are looking for a better
night's sleep is helix
sleep it's got a quiz you can
personalize it you can
make it your own they send it to you in
this cool
space age container then pops up
and folds itself unfolds itself it walks
over to your bed it throws itself on
your bed frame
it doesn't do those last two things but
it does
give you a personalized night of sleep
it's the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired you see how we
do that there
we're always trying to get you the good
stuff here at yang speaks
if you go to helixsleep.com yang and
take their two minute sleep quiz you'll
learn something about yourself
but then they'll also match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
10-year warranty try it for 100 nights
risk-free
so if you're insane you could order a
mattress sleep on it for 99 nights and
say don't like it
um if you did that they would be like oh
those yang
speaks people are terrible but hey you
know that's their policy serves them
right right
and helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners i love
deals at helixsleep.comyang
that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off so i um i'm
moving out of my apartment in new york
and i still had my old mattress after
been sleeping on this and i just for fun
like
jumped on the old one and then jumped on
the new one and this thing is freaking
awesome
it's a no-brainer and we've got a great
deal and even if you tried out for 100
nights
the risk risk-free you still have a
10-year warranty
um if something god forbid ever breaks
you don't like it so
they'll pick it up for if you don't love
it make it easy for you so
helixsleep.com
yang for up to hundred dollars off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at yank speaks that's
helix sleep.com
all right so i know the polls had
hillary winning for the most part
uh donald trump shocked the world there
are real problems trying to
suss out levels of support in in
some of these areas um but here are some
of the things that make me totally
confident
now number one the polls have been
pretty consistent and i'm just gonna
oversimplify for a second but
uh the the polls have joe at let's call
it plus seven nationally
uh plus eight nationally uh and then you
think well national doesn't matter
um so if you start trying to adjust it
for the electoral college for the swing
states and the rest of it
you have something like a three-point
built in electoral advantage for trump
um so if joe biden were up three um then
it'd be
essentially tied if that's the way the
vote's netted out
because uh is that what we mean
what do you mean that that you have to
uh that there's a natural advantage for
republicans right now because uh their
popular votes
correspond to a slightly higher number
of electoral votes okay because about
because of how the electoral college
works
and yeah just because of the way the
electoral college is structured so
so if you look at that you can see that
they have something like a three-point
um built-in advantage uh some people are
very mad about this when i say this out
loud but you know i mean
that's the math what are you gonna do
where's the numbers uh yeah the numbers
the numbers
so but three three's not eight so so
if joe's up by seven or eight and then
uh
you've got like a three point cushion
the other direction joe's still up four
or five
uh one of the things that
really held hillary back last time is
that people did not like her
and i talked to a lot of voters even in
2016 even though i wasn't even in
politics like i heard from folks in
michigan that were just so anti-hillary
a lot of people did not like hillary
joe does not generate that kind of
hostility or animosity that there's just
not this
huge wellspring of um
anger and venom and uh you know the
sense that that
uh um he's morally askew or something
like that
uh and i'm not saying this stuff was
fair to hillary but there was definitely
a lot of stuff that still existed yeah
yeah um
so so you take that off the board um
then you take the fact that last time
people voted for trump there was
something of an unknown as to how he
would govern and now everyone knows
how there's like no ambiguity i talked
to thousands
of trump supporters on the trail who
said you know i i'm not sure this is
what i want to re-up for
like they were disappointed then i have
a feeling they're more disappointed now
um so if you can imagine trump losing
10 12 of the folks that voted for him
last time
uh because they didn't get what they
thought they were going to get which i
think is
realistic then you start getting a more
complete picture of trump having like
this very very low ceiling it's one
reason why everyone's saying it's like
well he could pull it off if he gets
this narrow track of states but you're
seeing his overall approval rating has
been way below 50 percent
forever you know he hasn't even sniffed
it uh
it's just going to be very very hard
even with some of the map advantages he
has
to get to a point where he's going to
win the momentum is not on his side
if anything the momentum steered the
other way joe has a massive cash
advantage
which is going to help at the margins
they've been getting economies of scale
on national advertising that
trump has not i happen to watch
some florida based tv the other day um
because of it it was again uh i've been
sure
ads because of expressvpn yeah and
stuff it was nonstop it was nonstop
political ads there were some trump
superpac ads in there
but there was a whole lot of joe and
that was on some major programs too
i think i was watching it because of
an nfl game or something like that it
was expensive advertising
and joe was all over it um and it's not
just that program joe's everywhere
they've got 180 million dollars more to
spend on ads or whatnot uh
and all of that money is just going
straight into the airwaves
um so is that you know is that
everything no but is it nothing no you
know i mean like
so so when you start building this
picture um
you settle on the fact that this time
uh trump's gonna lose uh he he's not
gonna
pull this thing out and this is someone
who very much respects
uh the fact that companies get it wrong
data's not people uh you know like
there are some unknowables um
but i've talked to thousands of voters
and
it's consistent you know i talked to a
friend the other day whose stepmom is
uh an 80 year old in missouri who voted
for trump but she's like not this time
like they're just a lot of not not this
time
not against out there right so
i think there's an argument like he
probably didn't grow his base too much
more given toronto virus or the past
four years of
that we're all exhausted of so i i
definitely see that in
lord i hope you're right i wanna i wanna
play devil's advocate before that i
think i wanna ask a question i think
it's really important
is um when you ran andrew we ran
we talked a lot about um donald is a
symptom
we need to cure the disease and the
states
michigan ohio wisconsin pennsylvania are
some of the states hit hardest by
automation manufacturing um
and you also said look either i'm going
to win this thing or the winner is going
to sound like me
do you think um
the biden campaign has done a good
enough job like getting to those
those types of voters and talking about
either this or a different vision for
the country
or has that not mattered as much
in the the public zeitgeist if you will
because of coronavirus what are your
thoughts on like your core message still
being applied on election day
i don't think joe has needed to go down
this road uh
and i i think that
the real challenge if andrew gang is
correct uh and also our processes hold
up not a given
um and that votes are counted and
there's an orderly
transfer of power and joe gets sworn in
january 2
first
really to me that then the work begins
uh you know you need to work work work
to win this election
i'm working very hard to try and grow
the number of members of congress that
are for
cash relief and so you know like where
we're working uh
but then the real work begins
after you're in power whether you
actually
make enough big changes so that the
problems that got trump elected
don't just fester and grow and there's
been a consistent narrative
from a number of people that i find very
very interesting and we're going to find
out one way or another
and here's the narrative you all heard
it i think
that trump for all of his problems
uh is not as
competent a fascist as you can imagine
arising from a truly disintegrating
civilization where if we don't solve the
problems that got trump elected
something else comes out of the same
set of ideas and impulses and people
and that person could be worse than
trump that person could be
competent and malignant as well as
narcissistic
you know that that person could um
really
put much more
design into some of the
darker tendencies that trump represented
whereas trump was kind of
bull in china shop like that that was
his vibe and approach
um and i think that's
one concern that i find by the way
totally legitimate
uh nature reports a vacuum and the rest
of it uh you know like
does the post-presidency trump remain
trump are there like other versions that
kind of spin out
in various ways you know there's this
massive level of energy
around uh some of these ideas and
conspiracy theories and impulses from
the fact that q anon
has become an actual political movement
despite just starting out as
um internet conspiracy theories you know
i mean that
that's pretty wild so uh
so the challenges are going to begin
almost after election day and
you're sworn in uh the the thing that
philip howard said really stuck with me
he said the parties have been playing
you lose i lose you lose i lose all the
time
while we have been losing ourselves or
like the people have been losing
and the temptation for
joe and the dems is going to be we won
we beat trump
everything's back to normal we can just
do our thing
and because we're sane and rational and
well-intended
um uh all should be well and uh you
should
believe in us uh and a lot of americans
don't believe
because uh they just don't think that
our government is working for them
uh and actually solving the problems
they see around them uh
the fact that we don't have a stimulus
relief bill by the way is
exhibit uh 378 and their list of like
why i don't believe in government
it's an awfully big exhibit it's like a
bigger exhibit than some of the others
so the challenge
uh is going to be manifold but it's
strengthening the connection between
government and
the reality on the ground for many
americans if we don't build up that
connection we don't build up the trust
the mistrust is just going to grow the
institutional
deterioration is just going to grow uh
and
the danger is that we become uh
increasingly
ungovernable and unable to solve
meaningful problems over time
i think this is the real danger i i
think we're going to win this election
uh and then the question is whether we
go big enough and whether we
rebuild in a way that's robust enough
and i know this if and let's say when we
win
um there are people like you people like
aoc people like
a lot of the candidates we've endorsed
that will not let this administration
and we'll be allies to them as much as
we can but we'll not let them be
complacent as if things are normal like
you are
step one on a long road to recovery is
kind of what you're saying
you being the biden administration and a
good step one
every day you're seeing a new story
about how our personal privacy is being
invaded and it's not just the social
media sites watching our every move
it's that device in the home it's the
smart speaker it's your smart tv
everything's smart which means
everything has ears
if companies that pay next to nothing in
taxes are going to track what you do
online shouldn't you get compensated for
a little bit of that
and since we're still fighting for that
you can do the next best thing and
protect yourself
with a service that i trust and use to
keep my information safe expressvpn
it encrypts your internet data hides
your ip address so that
your even your isp provide your provider
can't track you
uh you can download it it's very easy
it's like one
button and then poof you're in the
internet someplace else
uh if you have expressvpn you're joining
folks in using the number one vpn
by wired cnet the verge it's less than
seven bucks a month and if you don't
like it there's a 30 day money back
guarantee
and there's a deal for our listeners
protect your online privacy today with
expressvpn
and because you're tuning in to this
show
you can get three months of expressvpn
protection for free when you visit
expressvpn.com
yang that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
yang for three months free with a
one-year package expressvpn.com
[Music]
all right here's what i think andrew i'd
like to do this um
for those of you listening who maybe
disagree with andrew or like
terrified um i'm i
this is where i'm gonna play the devil's
advocate race like how does trump win
um because i actually think so i think
it's either one of two scenarios this is
my gut it's either
this election was over in march over and
biden rolls by just freaking rolls like
texas is close he wins jordan he wins
some like states like
how the hell did democrat win that like
in just the landslide um
and i think that's most likely and boy
god damn i'm literally gonna be praying
on my knees for that outcome because we
need that
um we need to get the country right the
other outcome to me is that
similar to 2016 the polls are wrong and
i think
um they're wrong because either the
turnout model's wrong or there's a lot
of people that
don't want to admit they're voting for
trump um and if that's
ah the shy trump voter good old shy
trump voter
good old shy trump voter and i know that
i mean i know they exist if the question
is the number that exists and you don't
really
have to tell um and if that's the case i
think a trump victory looks like this
it's an inside straight again
he wins florida ohio north carolina
you throw in i think he wins iowa i
think we're overreaching there
and then the one where the polls are
just dead wrong just like they were in
2016 pennsylvania
and trump biden's up i think i can look
this up real quick he's up in
pennsylvania
somewhere the polls range right now
between biden plus eight to trump plus
three and it's leaning more biden plus
eight
but if the polls are wrong and trump
squeaks that out um
he now just needs a couple more yeah i
think he's at like 269 or 270 there
right there with those states he needs
either arizona new hampshire
nebraska district two ever is our main
district two um they've got a couple
states that split their electoral votes
and to me where that where i think this
could lean is because
and these tight [ __ ] like voting
counting issues or stuff advantage
incumbent
um so that to me is how trump sneaks
this out
um and so that's my call i
i hope i'm wrong um but i'm terrified
well that way that's what
that's that's your call as in that's
what you're predicting trump wins it
that's the lane man i think he does it i
think we have [ __ ] man i
i think zach i hate it and i mean i mean
necessarily been helping but i hope if
you're listening this like
you're scared like i am like i'm going
to watch this election in florida and
monday tuesday i'll be out there trying
to bring random strangers to
go vote knock on neighbors doors
whatever i can
i think this is a tremendous note for
everyone because despite andrew yang's
confidence
i have the capacity to be confident and
also run through the tape and work hard
um but if you're not that type you
should run through the sheets not
because
because that because zach just scared
the confidence out of you
so we we definitely need to work work
work and until the polls
close on tuesday every vote matters uh
especially in the swing states so
that that's a scenario you've traced
zack
that requires a lot to go right for
trump but it's plausible uh
no it's not that if you look at it's not
that far fetched that's what scared me
because it's like i think he wins
florida
and ohio and north carolina so then it's
pennsylvania needs to flop
and then one other like one other
like holy [ __ ] he won nevada like nevada
they say like or whatever it is or what
michigan was off like
yeah he needs to win he needs to win a
pa
uh or something along those lines it's
one reason why i've been campaigning in
pa i mean the biden campaign knows that
pa is key
yeah uh pennsylvania and florida those
those feel like the the giant boulders
like if one
if they both jump drop to trump um then
the scenario you
just outlined is very realistic and it's
it's one of those things that's crazy
like if one of these states is off like
the likelihood of other ones being
really off is it gets higher right
that's where you're you know it's kind
of how this is what happened in 2016
yeah you looked up and you were like
wait what then pennsylvania what the
hell
yeah yeah and you're like and i think
that's a wrap then i remember and i
remember the anchors looking up
being like i think that does it
i remember watching me like i thought a
couple of these dates would be close so
that wisconsin's gonna be close that
mission can be closed but i thought we
had
pennsylvania locked i thought florida
was looking okay um
and when they started dropping man
you're like wait wait wait uh wait a
what
um so um now look there's a plenty of
positive movement
if you want to like sleep better at
night look donald trump had lower
turnout in
2016 than mitt romney did in 2012. like
um so there is if the dems show up i
think they can
there could be the title wave um and i
do think like half my gut tells me this
election was over in march
like if people saw the response to kova
they're like oh man wrong guy wrong time
like got it or it might have been wrong
after the first debate because that was
very very negative for trump uh you know
and then he followed it up by getting
coveted very very nasty a few days for
him
yeah you know like that was like a
one-two punch uh and then
after that i don't know what he could
have done to to reverse it
and i think and that's where like the
evaluation needs to take place because i
think like in 2016 like you could argue
trump deserved to win like he had a
really powerful message and he went to
where the people who liked that message
needed to hear it right this case he
does not have a very powerful message
and he's going to these places in ways
that are dangerous like it's a
freaking pandemic right now like the his
everything's off like
i don't think he deserves to win this
from a tactics standpoint for what it's
worth
uh the story about the people being
stranded at the uh nebraska post rally
or one night
i was like oh no i feel so bad for you
it was like really cold apparently
for those who didn't see this donald
trump had a rally in nebraska
and a couple hundred like basically they
shuttled them into basically an airport
hangar
a couple miles away and the buses got
held up or
left or ignored so basically a couple
hundred supporters got stuck in the cold
and the dark like it was just like it
was over
um which is probably more of a funny
like
make fun of trump story than losing
supporters stuff but uh
this sounds like a setup for a movie or
something it sounds like a version of
uh fire fest or um uh andrew and i have
written a movie guys
and uh it's called blood caucus and it's
uh
a murder horror movie takes place at the
iowa caucuses
uh more to come soon um among i don't
tell you
candidates for the the um
democratic nomination it has a tagline
your first vote could be your last could
be your lincoln work
your work of genius yeah genius how did
we just give away our hit screen play
zack
delete delete delete delete cut this out
but let me just like the movie logo is
the iowa state flag
with the eagle on it it's like red it's
red white and blue with this eagle in
the middle of it and it's got like uh
there's like blood dripping off the
talons like something sick right uh
yeah this is a hit man definitely a
banger uh
we should we should design john our
producer john we're going to draft this
up
um see if we can get some momentum
around it we'll crowdfund around our
first
for the pilot or whatever the first the
raw the rough cut
sorry back to election um
i'll be uh in and out of cnn studios uh
over uh the next number of days
uh to to peek in it's interesting zach
because
part of the lens we see things through
is like the reaction to journalists to
various things
and i have no idea how i'd react to
various things
like i hope you give me like a wtf on
air uh if something crazy happens like
if texas flips drop an f-bomb or
whatever
[Laughter]
so uh so i i obviously believe joe's
gonna win
um and so that that that's uh
so that's my prediction yeah i took the
other side
i will say good i i will say zach's
upside for calling trump is much higher
than than mine because if zack is right
then everyone will be like
zach's genius uh that's true this is
exactly this is me 20 24
big code guy 2024 etc
let's all just listen to zach uh or if
not you call me an idiot right
um it's here's a i say so um on
wednesday
this week um we're gonna try and give
some live reaction so andrew's
schedule's gonna be all over the place
but it'll be
myself um and hopefully
friends from our our world so as many
political experts as we get including
i'm sure our press our comms team will
be involved um
carly or eric sanchez our staffers going
to try and loop them in um
especially if andrew can't join i think
he's gonna be tied up so you'll have
both
yang live on cnn and zach and the yang
gang staff
live on yank speaks i think it'll be a
fun way to look at the election
so fun let's do it let's yang gang uh
come together yang gang gather for
elections
day and night results uh one thing i
would love for you to pour over
i would do it and if i'm available i
will do it i want to go through all the
humanity forward candidates
and what happened with their races i now
oh yeah i'm so passionate about so many
of these candidates i'm going to be
pumped when they win and very sad if
they don't win because i feel like they
all deserve to win
some of them have very tough races but
if you're listening to this and you can
help in any of the humanity forward
races
please check it out go to
movehumanityforward.com
who knows it could be the person running
in your district and then you can go
vote for them
but let's help them win that's going to
be to me
a massive uh like emotional
high or low what happens with those
candidates
because having been a candidate myself i
see what they put on the line
and if they win some of them they win
that it's going to be historic because
some of them are awesome
candidates and human beings but running
in districts where
no one gave them a shot in the beginning
but now some of them do have a shot
yeah the best thing we can do to broaden
what you stand for andrew is actually
empowering the people we've
we've tasked with carrying the torch you
know we've given up who are carrying the
torch
so that's movement forward you can
actually donate to all of them like if
you only have five bucks to donate you
can give
a little fraction to all of them which
is you know pennies i guess so please
give more than that if you're doing that
but uh
like you can give you can see them all
um and they need like joe biden like
um they're good on money i think down
the stretch here
they're good like you know but some of
these smaller candidates really could
like you know
100 bucks or whatever you can give
actually would go a decent way because
they're doing a lot of facebook ads
or flyer printing and get out the vote
efforts day of and that's
that actually carries some weight in
some of these small towns too so i've
donated to our candidates
uh it's just so fun you can't resist
um and then after you donate there's a
magical connection that is forged
some of you have that connection with me
for which i'm eternally grateful yeah
because you now get expanded
email no they're good
you know sorry that makes me super sad
man
no i mean like we do spam but it's not
it's uh
they're thoughtful they're hard that
it's not you know clickbait bs
i think that's an oxymoron bro i don't
think you can i don't think this is a
thing of thoughtful spam why don't you
get back into that that's fair
that's fair um but you guys have been
great a lot of you guys open them which
i appreciate because we do put a lot we
do put a lot of time and thought into
writing them andrew writes a bunch
himself um he's actually we're working
on one
you know what we want to say you know in
the election so um
they're real thank you for opening them
sorry i derailed you on our
space no not at all
[Laughter]
but a magical connection is built when
you make a donation to a candidate
and i i have had that experience myself
so if you want
to root even harder for candidate
election night just make a
donation 10 20 bucks to them and then
all of a sudden you'll be like that's my
guy or that's my gal or that's my
candidate
um so i'd encourage you to do so it
really is magical
that connection it's one reason why i
think those organic campaigns
like ours end up being so much stronger
uh because you feel like you own it uh
you
begin through your support and like it
or not
uh that that includes financial support
um there's something very direct and
powerful about it
you know what's cool andrew that we
actually don't talk about enough is that
you interview every candidate
we endorse or about to endorse um
and no offense to barack obama he makes
a lot of endorsements i highly doubt
he's doing that
um like you get to know them personally
and there have been times
um where you're like you know i don't
know if this is you know like you'll
you want to get to know that on a
personal level to make sure they um that
frankly the yang gang or anyone's
donating to them
um yeah i personally interview them and
i personally donate to them
uh if if we decide to go forward and
i've definitely talked to someone i've
been like i don't know if this is the
the way or this is the fit because i'd
feel terrible
endorsing someone if i didn't have that
direct experience with them
even if it is a half an hour zoom or
phone call
and you can go a long way with a half an
hour zoomer phone call and getting
um into someone's head and seeing what
makes them tick and now i love those
candidates
i'll tell you like if i'd endorsed them
and i hadn't had that conversation with
them would i feel as strongly as i do
heck no
maybe a phony yeah but now i'm so
into it i'm so into each and every one
of them
they're awesome i don't want to name
names it's like having some you know but
like
donna david kim kara eastman in nebraska
in that district you're talking about
the folks who are at yank speaks last
week
uh pam keith allen cohn
uh you know though this just goes on and
on i love them all should you call
carney
like lula cycly anyway
uh they're all awesome dude do check
them out and movehumanityforward.com
let's help them win that's going to be a
roller coaster for me
on election night because i can already
see some of them are going to win i'm
sure some of them are not going to win
because many of them have very
challenging races
but i'm going to be like yes yes oh no
yes oh no and then i'll i'll be you know
and some of you won't know
i'll be texting them too i'll be all
like yeah
so excited or like you did great anyway
um yeah anyway so election night it's
gonna be a huge night
let's make it even better make sure and
vote you can still make a difference
you can still donate you can still
volunteer you can still do all sorts of
things zach's volunteering in florida
i'm volunteering at cnn hq
they're paying me but
please vote guys we love you um we love
this country
we love the humans running for office
win lose or draw
if you're on you know whatever team
you're on the important thing that we
come together and we hope um
you're here with us on this podcast to
kind of talk about the results shortly
after so thank you guys
go vote vote even if it's not for anyone
we are talking about just vote
no like guest vote amen thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]